since we learned about the supreme court
decision that will overturn roe v wade
ending abortion as a right and allowing
states to up to and completely ban
abortion if they so please
one of the things i've been talking
about is that it is very unlikely the
right will be satisfied with just this
and will be willing to just say okay we
got rid of the the abortion thing we're
done we're satisfied when you have
arguably one of your biggest wins in
decades you don't say well that's it
we're done you try to do more and one of
the things i said is that there will be
efforts
to go further and these efforts might
include maybe trying to overturn the
supreme court decision that ultimately
legalized gay marriage by banning bans
on gay marriage that's one possibility
uh overturning a co-payment free
contraception as part of obamacare
and we included in this what about
interracial marriage and of course
that's more far-fetched although there
are some people who are against uh
abortion who are uh against
interracial marriage as well although it
is a little bit more extreme so
some of you have uh called in and
written to me and said david that's an
imaginary slippery slope that's not
really likely to happen and i think
you're very wrong and i'm going to tell
you why first i do want to quickly tell
you about our sponsor policy genius if
someone relies on your income could be a
child a parent spouse business partner
it can be important to have life
insurance it's not fun i don't like
dealing with life insurance but i do it
because it's the right thing to do
many people don't have nearly the amount
of life insurance they need if they get
it from their employer as an example
having enough coverage is valuable in
terms of peace of mind and policy genius
simplifies the process you go to
david pakman show you answer just a few
questions they'll find the best deals
from top companies and when you're ready
to sign up they do everything for you
policy genius is free to use they don't
sell your information you can talk to a
licensed expert if you have questions
even if you have life insurance just
take the two minutes and see if you
could get a better deal you could save
50 or more by comparing quotes with
policy genius that's policy genius.com
david pakman show so our lgbt friends
um
many of them are understandably worried
as a result of what's happening with roe
v wade because quite simply
if the supreme court can start to say
precedent precedent
we don't care about precedent even
though they said they did these justices
during their supreme court confirmation
hearings and they say well roe v wade's
gone uh the obergefell case which banned
bans on same-sex marriage that could be
revised and that could be over
written and undone as well and i know
that we talk about um interracial
marriage no they're never really going
to come for that that would be crazy
well the point here is it wouldn't be
particularly more difficult legally
speaking than what they've done with roe
v wade and there are republicans talking
about this charlie kirk said
uh if roe v wade can be eliminated then
anything is possible
republican senator john cornyn
uh has tried to make the case that the
gay marriage decision obergefell v
hodges
was faulty and it was an edict of the
supreme court and that it should just be
eliminated and he seems to have an ally
there at least potentially in justice
samuel alito who whined in a speech to
the federalist society that religious
families are the real victims of gay
marriage that doesn't sound particularly
good to me
uh republican senator marsha blackburn
who famously asked joe biden supreme
court nominee katanji brown jackson to
define a woman during those confirmation
hearings blackburn said she's against
griswold v connecticut that's the
decision from 1965
which granted the right to privacy on
which roe v wade was based and it also
allowed married couples the right to buy
and use contraceptives without any
government restrictions she says that
was a constitutionally unsound decision
so right now the issue for me is less
about do republicans really want to ban
interracial marriage that's not
literally what i'm saying although there
are some republicans who do
uh i've interviewed some of them on my
show
it is more about
the legal
proceedings and process that led to roe
v wade going like that assuming that it
does and we are standing by for that
official decision but the decision has
been leaked
it could be applied in many other places
and there is an appetite from the right
for exactly that a lot of these one of
the arguments let me mention one other
thing
one of the arguments that was made for a
long time about why abortion shouldn't
be a right is that quote the
constitution doesn't mention it now
that's a fraught argument and we've
talked to constitutional law professors
who say
the constitution doesn't have to mention
something by name
for it to be okay
for
court decisions to enshrine a right that
that there's nothing fundamentally wrong
with that but
it is true that the supreme court also
doesn't measure mention the words gay
lesbian bisexual transgender queer etc
and although i don't think that's a good
argument and constitutional law
professors have told me that it's not a
good argument
it is an argument that could be used to
take away all sorts of other rights and
protections and so i expect that this is
not the end
i don't pretend to know how far they're
going to try to go
but it is going to be further than just
overturning roe v wade let me know your
thoughts in the comments